tu vois tu es difficile en fait ce que
vous faites c'est que vous leur donnez
la parole c'est dur pour un bavard et il
y a genre un record à battre mais à
Verdun avec des obus autour de nous
très fort pas mal c'est des petits
pièges ça c'est bien vu
Omar salut Hugo ça va très bien merci
d'avoir accepté ce moment cet échange
aujourd'hui j'ai un plaisir je suis
content d'être là dans un cadre
particulier en plus il faut le dire je
pense que les gens le voient mais on est
à Paris on a Verdun aujourd'hui au
Mémorial de Verdun plus précisément à
l'occasion de la sortie d'un film
tirailleurs qui sort le 4 janvier pour
l'interview tu le vois face à toi il y a
un écran
pour l'instant mon prénom est le nom de
la le nom de la chaîne exactement il va
y avoir des emojis qui vont défiler et
quand tu veux je t'inviterai à appuyer
sur ce puzzer qui va arrêter cette roue
et on va voir sur quel emoji
au fur et à mesure
et ça tombe sur un des faut faire un
pari alors pas tout à fait mais ça va
être une sorte de jeu tu en fait c'est
un tu préfères en gros tu vas avoir deux
propositions qui vont s'afficher à
l'écran je te laisse en choisir une si
tu y arrives
pas moi quand il faut choisir dans tous
les cas on va pouvoir en parler et
commenter je te laisse voir le premier
ah tu préfères Radio Nova intouchables
tu vois tu es difficile je sentais que
ça allait être un truc comme ça ou tu
peux pas choisir parce qu'en fait il
s'agit
de deux moments importants on va dire de
démarrage c'est à dire que Nova je fais
la découverte en fait de de ce métier en
fait de me dire que on peut faire
quelque chose de de ce que j'avais à
l'époque qui se forme de petit chat avec
quelques vannes et tout je découvre que
ben ça peut intéresser quelqu'un d'autre
que mes potes en fait c'était pas juste
mes potes qui pouvaient rire à mes
vannes donc ça je le découvre à Nova et
avec intouchable je découvre ce truc en
fait des tracteurs de faire du cinéma
avant ça je me pose jamais la question
de est-ce que j'aime faire ça donc Nova
je découvre un peu l'envie d'être de
venir on va dire ben comique en fait et
là acteur donc ces deux points de départ
et les deux se valent et puis ils sont
indissociables en fait c'est à dire que
c'est une étape qui mène l'une à l'autre
c'est l'un l'autre peu de gens savent
que tu as commencé chez Radio Nova
encore moins de gens savent que ça a
commencé avec Jamel Debbouze comment il
t'a repéré recruté comment ça s'est fait
en fait il m'a pas vraiment repéré
puisque on a on a grandi ensemble dans
le même quartier j'ai très ami avec son
petit frère donc il savait qui j'étais
et connaissait ma personnalité et un
jour il a eu besoin de moi pour ce truc
à Nova il m'a appelé ça devait être pour
ce jour-là seulement et puis je trouve
que je suis retourné là-bas tous les
jours quasiment pendant un an et demi tu
as fait confiance dessus et puis même
après sur Canal d'ailleurs il m'a fait
confiance et c'est ce qui m'a ce qui a
déclenché tout le reste en fait jusqu'à
un peu faible et tout le succès qui a eu
derrière on a un deuxième tu préfères
avant de passer à l'émoji suivant alors
c'est facile
je préfère le César parce que j'en ai
voilà
je connais ces armes je connais pas
Oscar mais j'aimerais bien le rencontrer
un jour mais pour l'instant je préfère
ces arbres parce que c'est lui mon pote
ce sera un autre défi aussi pour toi un
Oscar est-ce que tu penses que quand tu
as remporté un César aller commencer à
faire du cinéma à l'étranger aux
États-Unis précisément pour toi c'était
un nouveau défi c'est quelque chose tu
voulais faire depuis longtemps ou
franchement quand je suis parti aux
États-Unis en fait je suis même pas
parti pour le travail à la base j'étais
parti pour un tas de raisons qui n'avait
aucun lien avec le boulot j'avais
surtout envie d'avoir du recul par
rapport à ce qui se passait pour moi en
France en fait et justement par rapport
au César et donc j'ai pris un peu de
temps un peu de recul avec ce César et
je trouve que je suis aux États-Unis
j'ai resté un petit moment et là j'ai
rencontré un agent qui commence à me
faire des propositions je commence à
faire des castings c'est comme ça que ça
se fait tout doucement mais mais au
départ c'est pas du tout un truc que
j'ai visé quoi et après je pense qu'on
vise ni un César ni un Oscar on fait nos
projets on est le plus honnête possible
quand on le fait et puis la récompense
elle vient mais c'est un espèce de c'est
une conséquence mais je suis pas sûr
qu'on vise un Oscar ou un César ça
serait très chelou quoi se dire ouais ce
projet là je vais avoir un Oscar ou avec
ce projet là je vais avoir un CFA
footballeur et à limite le footballeur
peut vouloir à la Coupe du monde mais
parce que l'acteur il veut pas forcément
le oui mais c'est différent une coupe du
monde tu participes à la Coupe du monde
pour être champion du monde il y a des
étapes un peu obligatoire mais tu peux
très bien faire une carrière sans avoir
aucun César il y a plein de très grands
acteurs qui n'ont pas eu ces récompenses
là ils font une très belle carrière
exactement et encore une fois je dis
c'est c'est des récompenses mais c'est
pas une compétition le sport il y a des
compétitions mais nous on n'est pas dans
un sport en fait on va passer à l'emoji
suivant la roue tourne à nouveau je
t'invite à trier quand tu veux plein de
dynamises pour avoir choisi l'impact on
le sent un clap un clap on va voir ce
qui se cache derrière je pense que c'est
une vidéo et je vais t'en parler juste
après je vais t'expliquer pourquoi
est-ce qu'on regarde tout ça
on ne regarde pas
[Musique]
merci Madame
je vous l'avais dit
vous m'avez vu
vous m'avez pas regardé alors je voulais
te montrer ça non pas on va pas parler
du pain pendant une demi-heure mais
simplement parce que j'ai vu une sorte
de similitude entre Lupin et tirailleurs
évidemment les sujets n'ont rien à voir
mais dans la thématique ce que j'ai
trouvé très intéressant c'est que ces
deux projets sur lesquels tu as
travaillé ou tu mets en avant des
personnages des parcours des personnes
qui sont parfois méconnues alors on le
voit là c'était une bande annonce pour
Lupin t'incarne une personne de l'ombre
finalement qu'on qu'on ne voit pas
finalement au quotidien qu'on ne regarde
pas au quotidien dans tirailleurs il y a
un peu la même chose on va en reparler
beaucoup de fois aujourd'hui tu mets en
avant des parcours et une histoire
parfois méconnue c'est quelque chose qui
est important pour toi via le via le
cinéma ouais j'ai l'impression que c'est
quand même le bon endroit pour ça c'est
à dire mettre en lumière
des choses qui sont qui sont un peu su
ou peu que nous en tout cas dans l'ombre
et là pour le coup il s'agit de
personnes moi ça ça m'a
ça m'intéresse et ça me touche et je
trouve que ça vaut le coup en fait
finalement de de rappeler ça en fait les
gens qu'on ne voit pas qu'on écoute pas
ou qu'on oublie c'est assez terrible en
fait et pour et pour là pour le coup
pour parler de tirailleurs et c'est des
gens qui ont vraiment compté et qui à
qui on doit beaucoup la paix dans
laquelle on vit nous on la doit quand
même à des gens qui ont dû subir des
choses atroces pour qu'on se rende
compte que finalement c'est c'est
difficile il faudrait peut-être pas le
refaire et donc et donc les tirailleurs
on participait à cela libérer la France
et se battent pour elle donc de de juste
les oublier il y a quelque chose d'assez
dur et cruel quoi là-dessus dans le dans
le film vers la fin c'est pas un spoiler
pas d'inquiétude vers la fin ton
personnage dit justement souvenez-vous
de moi souvenez-vous de nous c'est vrai
que on peut rapidement et facilement
oublier l'histoire parce qu'il y a un
enchaînement d'événements non seulement
de choses on peut oublier que certaines
personnes se sont battues ils se passent
tellement de choses et puis on est dans
nos vies tout ça donc oui on oublie et
ça arrive mais au moins de pouvoir s'en
rappeler surtout à voir quelque chose
pour cela on est ici aujourd'hui
d'ailleurs au Mémorial à Verdun
justement pour pouvoir se rappeler pas
laisser juste l'oubli prendre place
parce qu'on sait justement que n'oublie
prend place rapidement donc juste avoir
un peu de matière pour pouvoir se
rappeler de tout ça et à ce propos
justement dans mes dans mes souvenirs
quand à l'école collège lycée on voyait
la Première Guerre mondiale on parlait
assez peu voire pas des tirailleurs donc
de ces personnes qui ont rejoint à
l'armée soit volontairement soit de
force des cas de beaucoup qui sont
retrouvés à se battre pour la France
parce qu'il faisait partie de colonie
française tu l'as aussi fait ce film
pour faire en sorte que dans les écoles
ou autres il puisse être diffusé un jour
ou oui bah on espère il y a un dossier
pédagogique qui accompagne le film mais
d'ailleurs on est là aujourd'hui pour
montrer le film a beaucoup d'élèves et
tout ça même si le film n'est pas un
cours d'histoire ou un exposé c'est
vraiment du cinéma mais il y a un
endroit effectivement où on citron un
petit peu où ça change un petit peu
justement du rapport qu'on a à l'école
où il y a très peu de choses la même au
musée il y a des traces des tirailleurs
mais mais ce que je parle avec
l'historien qui est ici qui m'a fait la
visite il a mis le mot dessus en fait
depuis le début de la promo je j'ai du
mal à le préciser lui il l'a fait
clairement il dit en fait ce que vous
faites c'est que vous leur donnez la
parole il y a beaucoup de témoignages
les choses qu'on a sont des témoignages
de qui sont rapportés par d'autres mais
les tirailleurs n'ont jamais eu la
parole parce que justement ils ne
parlaient pas français il n'équivait pas
le français donc il y a peu de traces
sur sur leur passage ici il y a peu sur
leur témoignages est-ce que le film
amène en plus effectivement c'est que eh
ben on leur donne la parole et c'est
important et dans un sous forme de film
d'un récit qui est très prenant plus
donc c'est j'imagine même pour des
jeunes qui vont voir le film dans les
prochains jours c'est quelque chose qui
est un impact qui a un impact très fort
on va passer à la question suivante je
relance la roue et je t'invite à nouveau
est-ce qu'on peut choisir un bruit ça
sera mon bruit je peux choisir et ça
deviendra le bruit maintenant de avec
grand plaisir
tu dois avoir une banque de données
quelque part tu dois avoir un geek tu
peux nous trouver ça mais au montage on
peut rajouter quelque chose si tu as une
idée de bruit on va chercher ensemble à
des bruits très bien alors là il y a une
petite bulle de parlage une petite bulle
de citation en général c'est une
citation qui a derrière je t'invite à la
lire si tu veux à voix haute et après
d'accord après cette grande bataille
vous ne serez plus considéré comme des
indigènes mais comme des Français est-ce
que ça te dit quelque chose c'est dans
le film ça ouais même dans la
bande-annonce oui c'est vrai que c'est
aussi dans la bande-annonce dans la
bande-annonce ouais c'est une phrase qui
a été prononcée par le général chambraud
avec interprété par François château
dans le film qu'est-ce qu'elle t'inspire
cette phrase mais en fait ce qui est
assez rigolo c'est qu'en fait c'est fait
beaucoup de dalles de champ en pleine
promo de ce film et je vois beaucoup de
journalistes et beaucoup ont été
interpellés par cette phrase et beaucoup
en fait ils sont interpellés par le
terme indigène
l'indigène le sauvage le gars qui vient
d'ailleurs etc tout ça et en fait on
oublie une chose en fait c'est que cette
phrase c'est aussi une promesse c'est
une promesse qui n'a pas été tenue
et en fait moi c'est plus ça que je que
j'entends quand je bois cette phrase en
fait c'est plus ça ça nous rappelle la
promesse faite à tous ces mecs là en
fait qui sont allés se battre à qui on a
promis quelque chose et à terme ben ça
c'est pas vraiment passé en plus donc
certains sont volontaires mais d'autres
sont engagés de force c'est le cas de
ton fils dans le dans le film donc il y
a eu des volontaires certains qui
espérait cette vie meilleure en France
que dans le fini ils imaginent cette vie
après la guerre ça a retenu sur mon
attention parce que dans l'actualité y
compris sur notre chaîne on parle
beaucoup de la crise migratoire beaucoup
de ce sujet là et j'ai vu une sorte de
parallèle je sais même pas je mets les
volontaires dans le film mais sur ces
personnes qui vont prendre des risques
là c'est l'enquête d'une guerre mais
autrement ça peut être en traversant la
Méditerranée et qui vont espérer une vie
meilleure peut-être en France derrière
c'est quelque chose à qui te parle et
que tu as vu aussi bien sûr mais toute
façon ça me parle mais c'est justement
ce que le film me raconte aussi c'est
qu'en fait ce lien entre les deux pays
c'est-à-dire entre les pays d'origine là
on va prendre le single parce qu'il
s'agit de ça et qu'il s'agit de ça me
concernant en fait on pense toujours à
ce voyage dans ce sens-là en fait c'est
d'ailleurs de l'Afrique à la France mais
en fait faut se rappeler que le début de
cette histoire commence quand même par
la France qui va en Afrique coloniser
ces pays donc aujourd'hui ce lien qui
est là on ne voudrait le défaire et
l'arrêter d'un seul coup mais il faut
remonter un peu plus loin et se rendre
compte qu'en fait ça commence là le le
l'histoire commence là donc ça peut pas
s'arrêter comme ça il y a des choses à
faire parce que c'est la conséquence de
choses qui ont été faites avant en fait
et c'est une relation qui a été
commencée par la France donc il faut il
faut il faut quand même regarder aussi
les choses de cet angle là en fait on
peut pas s'arrêter à la crise migratoire
on peut pas s'arrêter ni même à 14-18 si
il faut remonter sur un contexte
beaucoup plus beaucoup plus large et
surtout une histoire qui remonte à
beaucoup plus loin et encore une fois
c'est un voyage qui s'est fait dans
l'autre sens parce qu'a commencé par un
voyage dans l'autre sens absolument on
va passer à la question suivante je
relance encore la roue il ne manque ce
bruit
justement de toi et quand le mettre sur
Terre à partir de maintenant
alors un chrono un chronomètre en fait
ce chronomètre toutes les personnes les
candidats à la prise dans celle tout le
monde est passé par ça c'est un oui non
en fait en 60 secondes je vais te poser
un maximum de questions et le plus
possible l'idée c'est de répondre par
oui ou par non à ces questions si tu
arrives encore là tu préfères d'accord
dire oui non sans développer quoi c'est
dur pour un bavard et alors il y a genre
un record à battre Angèle à parfaitement
joué le jeu elle a eu du oui non partout
Bill Gates à l'inverse c'était un ni oui
ni non avec lui pendant 60 secondes
il peut pas être comme tout le monde
sinon ce serait pas Bill Gates et donc
Angel elle a fait quoi parfait ça veut
dire elle a tout fait bien elle a fait
du oui non toutes les questions j'ai
même plus de questions à la fin aussi
regarde le nom qu'elle a c'est un ange
elle est parfaite tu es prêt j'essaye
est-ce que tu aimerais incarner un jour
James Bond au cinéma oui tu es optimiste
pour l'avenir oui tu es retourné à
l'Opéra depuis intouchables oui tu
aimerais que tirailleurs soit montré
dans les écoles oui l'argent fait-il le
bonheur non sur rogardes tes anciens
films oui si on ne proposait un
intouchable 2
tu as déjà triché lors d'un examen oui
est-ce que tu pourrais refaire service
après-vente non est-ce que tu as déjà
regretté d'avoir joué dans un film oui
est-ce que tu viens plus aux soirées si
j'y vais toujours est-ce que le cinéma
pollue trop non la vie est-elle
meilleure aux Etats-Unis oui jouer en
peu est-ce que c'est mieux que jouer en
anglais
je sais pas tirailleurs est-ce que c'est
le film qui te tient le plus à cœur
je sais pas tu pourrais faire un one man
show un jour non est-ce que tu aimerais
rejouer dans un Marvel oui très fort et
oui il restait 8 secondes j'ai même plus
de questions ou pas je pense que tu as
batturé franchement j'ai eu des je sais
pas
de je sais pas c'est parce que ça
méritait du développement c'est ça et
même sur les États-Unis ça mérite un
j'ai dit oui mais ça mérite un
développement
ta situation donc c'est ça
pas mal c'est des petits pièges ça c'est
mieux il est malin c'est pas facile la
rousse relance je te laisse à encore un
checker
vous voulez mettre un emoji d'oiseau il
s'avère que c'est un poussin mais en
théorie c'est un oiseau parce que c'est
un tweet que tu vas voir derrière donc
imagine que c'est un oiseau
parce que là en plus c'est un oiseau
jaune là
c'est un oiseau bleu il est mignon le
petit poussin en tout cas donc derrière
cette magie il y a un tweet je t'invite
à le découvrir il y a réagir à me dire
ce que ton ce que tu en penses mon chéri
pour le cinéma français serait de voir
plus souvent des films avec ce type de
casting mais qui est pas forcément pas
forcément de racisme et là on pourrait
dire qu'on a passé une étape alors
ensuite pour le contexte de Jérémy
delleau qui a un acteur youtubeur aussi
humoriste qu'est-ce que qu'est-ce que tu
en penses moi j'ai beaucoup de mal avec
les twitch je te dis la vérité c'est un
peu des trucs
justement un peu trop rapide comme ça
sentence comme ça un peu définitif et
puis qui sont des trucs un peu d'humeur
et moi j'aime pas réagir à chaud en fait
et ça ça doit être une réaction à chaud
après je comprends un peu l'idée de dire
que oui en fait dès qu'on a de la
délicité dans un casting forcément c'est
qu'on parle du racisme
c'est un peu vrai c'est un peu vrai
quelque part mais j'ai le sentiment
quand même qu'on bouge par exemple tu
vois de voir le film aujourd'hui
tirailleurs le film qu'on fait c'est
quand même la preuve que
on est en train d'avancer un minimum et
que on commence à raconter des histoires
un peu différentes alors c'est sûr ça
manque énormément et on est un peu à la
bourre mais on a du changement et bon
parce que chacun pense ce qu'il veut de
ce qu'on a fait au bon Dieu c'est
qu'est-ce qu'on a fait au bon Dieu et je
pense que au-delà d'ailleurs de ce film
là franchement c'est un sujet plus large
oui mais justement en fait moi je pense
que le racisme effectivement pour le
dépasser il faut arrêter d'en parler je
suis d'accord avec l'idée mais il est en
train de le faire et pour toi ça passe
par quoi du coup c'est le fait justement
de faire des films qui euh qui change
raconter des histoires différentes qui
ne parlent très qui c'est le plus un
sujet en fait moi c'est pas un sujet
pour moi donc je le traite pas je
raconte l'histoire de gens en fait qu'on
a oublié ou que ou que voilà des
histoires qui me touchent qui méritent
pour moi d'être connu de en fait de
faire des des
raconter des histoires où il y a
une forme de rencontre avec avec l'autre
est-ce qu'on connaît pas et c'est comme
ça finalement qu'on dépasse le racisme
en fait donc dès que j'ai des trucs
comme ça sur lesquels on doit s'exprimer
ça m'emmerde parce que justement j'ai
l'impression d'être encore dans les
années 80 moi c'est plus un sujet pour
moi mais les gens qui parlent de racisme
ils vivent dans le passé alors je sais
que c'était l'actrice asmaga qui en
avait parlé dans une tribune il y a
quelques années c'était le fait que des
personnes racisées dans des films soient
souvent
mises dans des films pour justement
traiter certains sujets notamment la
question du racisme alors que le vrai
enjeu il est de faire en sorte que on
fasse plus attention à ça que ce soit
plus un sujet finalement un sujet en
fait qu'on est des personnes dans des
films puis voilà et puis on raconte tout
simplement d'autres histoires et même
les mêmes histoires avaient d'autres
acteurs sans faire attention de tiens on
a pris un tel ou un tel parce qu'il est
comme si ou parce qu'il est comme ça je
trouve que quand on est là on est encore
pour moi dans le passé et ça m'intéresse
pas moi et je trouve qu'on a on a mieux
à raconter en plus que ce genre de de
d'histoire là c'est ce qu'on va aller
dans pas dans le film dans le film ici
on va lancer la question suivante je
relance la roue
[Musique]
en gros derrière ce cadeau c'est une
question qui vient d'un autre invité qui
était venu justement participer à cette
interview face cachée avant donc je te
laisse découvrir qui c'est et je te
laisse après évidemment répondre à la
question
bon alors qu'est-ce qu'il veut bien on
va voir qu'est-ce que derrière
je vais te poser une question et je
pense qu'on doit pas souvent de poser
cette question là donc je me dis
pourquoi pas je voudrais savoir quelle
est ta chanson préférée de tous les
temps si tu pouvais nous chanter un
petit extrait un petit pas à chanter si
tu pouvais me dire pourquoi et Angel en
fait est un petit démon mais dans la
merde dans la me faire chanter non c'est
une bonne question parce que encore une
fois c'est comme le tu préfères c'est
dur de choisir une chanson comme c'est
dur de choisir un film parce qu'en fait
les films que tu aimes revoir ou les
chansons que tu aimes écouter c'est
quand même un truc d'humeur je trouve
justement il y a des moments où il y a
des gens il y a une bonne chance la
chanson qui te fait danser celle qui te
fait réfléchir un peu voyager celle que
tu veux écouter quand tu es un peu
énervé enfin voilà il y a la musique
c'est compliqué mais celle de tous les
temps c'est écoute en ce moment là
j'hésite entre deux en fait
lesquels
Jackson OK et puis le tubers de Bob
Marley pas du tout le même style mais
c'est des chansons que j'aime bien
écouter et effectivement c'est peut-être
une chanson que j'aime écouter dans
n'importe quel état c'est qu'il y a des
chansons qui sont qui me demandent un
état particulier et c'est là peut-être
ces deux-là un peu
n'importe quand et me font du bien les
deux donc j'ai un peu du mal à choisir
là et un côté tu préfères
mais j'aime bien la musique en général
et je suis curieux alors après je suis
un peu plus sensible à la fin que La
Saule le reggae aussi voilà j'ai c'est
dracinant après j'écoute aussi de la
musique africaine de par mes origines et
ma sensibilité voilà
génétique peut-être je sais pas quoi
mais il y a un truc comme ça qui me
rappelle et tout ça les voies maliennes
après avec le film intouchable j'ai
commencé à écouter de la musique
classique aussi
mais c'est récent c'est vraiment ça date
de du film avec intouchable donc
tu rigoles bien sûr non mais ça c'est
justement son eau classique nous on a
écouté du rap mais surtout de la fin et
qu'en fait notre génération écoutez là
maintenant nos grands frères écoutez de
la funk et de la soul par exemple Bob
Marley Michael Jackson c'est mais c'est
mes grands frères qui m'ont fait
découvrir tout ça mais du film c'est
d'ailleurs un bon vecteur de découverte
de musique moi c'est tumbler j'étais
petit quand il y avait intouchable mais
j'ai découvert avec avec intouchable
quoi il y a tellement de musique que tu
découvres c'est la beauté du cinéma
d'ailleurs qui fait qui fait ça mais en
plus ça c'est vraiment des classiques ça
passe tout les temps donc c'est dur de
choisir entre les deux mais pour
répondre à Angèle je veux dire Bob
Marley très bon choix un doudou Bob
Marley du congel parce que comme tu l'as
demandé
Billy Billy
c'est improbable quand on y pense oui
à Verdun avec des obus autour de nous et
on est en train de chanter du Bob Marley
on passe à la question suivante je
relance la roue je crois que c'est la
dernière en plus la dernière émotion
un haut-parleur musique boum boum boum
Marley derrière
une question de Bob Marley non
il est venu ici on va voir ce qu'il y a
derrière et ensuite on va on va en
parler
ça c'est la réplique que dit biramar à
Bacary que Toi seul qui arrivera pas et
finalement il arrive tout seul alors
c'est un extrait pas du film en
l'occurrence mais d'une interview que
t'avais donné à Télérama il y a quelques
jours quelques temps maintenant même
plus longtemps pourquoi est-ce que je
voulais voir cet extrait là parce que
dans le film on parle peul et je pense
que beaucoup de gens en regardant le
film découvriront peut-être le pull pour
la première fois des Français qui ont
pas forcément connu cette langue là
comment est-ce que tu peux la présenter
pour ceux qui n'y connaissent rien et
qui veilleront le voir alors pour la
présenter le peu le fait c'est une
langue qui est parlée en Afrique de
l'Ouest subsa rien comme ça et puis
comme ça même jusqu'à l'ouest comme
parce qu'en fait c'est la langue d'un
peuple nomade en fait c'est un peuple et
qui voyage un peu comme ça donc la
transhumance quoi pour suivre de quoi
faire manger les bêtes et en fait tu
parles un peu partout dans l'Afrique et
donc elle est énormément parlé donc au
Sénégal au Mauritanie au Mali même en
Côte d'Ivoire je crois en Guinée au
Niger enfin il y a beaucoup beaucoup de
Peuls un peu partout et donc je parle un
peu loin ayant un père sénégalais mais
en Bretagne il parle tous les deux pulls
moi j'ai grandi dans le pull en fait
c'est comme ça que je parle avec mes
parents on parlait peu à la maison et et
à l'extérieur le français donc c'est une
langue que je c'est ma langue maternelle
en fait et c'était prévu dès le début
que tu joues dans cette langue son
aurait pu dire il y a plein de films
finalement qui sont dans une langue en
théorie mais ils utilisent une autre là
le fait de parler peu dans le film
c'était un choix oui c'était un choix en
fait qui qui
me permettait en fait de bien de bien
décrire ce qu'on avait envie de décrire
c'est-à-dire ces hommes qui étaient
arrachés à leur terre alors culture à
tous leurs repères et qui venait en
France et que du coup n'avait même pas
la communication aussi et même entre eux
en fait on dit littéraire sénégalais
mais même entre eux ils se comprenaient
pas puisqu'il parlait pas la même langue
donc c'était important pour nous de
raconter ça et puis aussi dans le film
il y a ce truc qui va cette relation
entre ce père et ce fils va se dégrader
parce que le fils va prendre l'avantage
et le fils prend l'avantage parce que
lui parle le français pas le père donc
pour tout ça comme ça servait aussi la
dramaturgie mais aussi c'était un moyen
de bien décrire ce qu'on voulait montrer
dans le film Le peuple il s'est imposé
assez rapidement et puis comme c'est la
seule langue africaine que je parle le
choix était vite fait c'était la bonne
chose mais ça montre aussi c'est super
intéressant de t'en parler la façon dont
le la langue peut-être une forme de
rapport de force voir de violence
d'ailleurs dans certains cas bien sûr et
plus largement au-delà de la question de
la langue comment est-ce qu'on se
prépare pour un film comme celui-ci en
plus il y a une grosse dimension
historique forcément on parle de 14-18
on parle de la guerre comment tu te
prépares pour un film comme ça est-ce
que c'est en échangeant avec
des descendante tirailleurs est-ce que
c'est en plongeant dans ce cette époque
en fait j'ai beaucoup discuté avec le
metteur en scène et j'ai profité de lui
vis ces documenter il a lu beaucoup donc
moi je venais récupérer un peu ce que
lui en avait tiré sur tout ce que lui
voulait garder pour le film donc c'est
beaucoup dans nos échanges par rapport à
ce que lui récoltait j'ai fait ça pas
mal et puis après moi j'ai fait aussi
mon petit travail d'à côté à se préparer
comme ça
j'ai notamment j'en parle beaucoup ça en
fait ce livre de David job faire dame
qui a été pris Goncourt je sais plus en
quelle année là des lycéens qui étaient
une vraie baffe pour moi parce que
c'était vraiment
typiquement ce qu'on avait envie de
faire avec tirailleurs c'est-à-dire de
raconter cette guerre de 14 qu'on
connaît qu'on sait mais mais avec un
autre regard en fait avec eux dans une
autre dimension avec un angle
particulier et en plus c'était l'angle
de deux tirailleurs aussi qui venaient
du Sénégal donc c'est vrai que ce livre
là il m'a un peu préparé il m'a un peu
mis dans l'ambiance il vraiment même
traverser le corps quoi c'était assez
intéressant ce que m'a fait ce livre là
et j'ai l'impression que finalement il
m'a préparé en fait pour le film mais
pour Bacary ce bouquin vu que tu en
avais fait une lecture d'ailleurs pour
France Culture j'ai poussé le truc où
j'ai fait une lecture à Avignon un soir
parce que j'avais ce texte là il m'avait
vraiment imprégné puis j'avais envie de
me l'approprier un petit peu plus mais
après le poids de l'histoire de
l'histoire du fait historique toute
cette précision c'est pas l'acteur qui
la porte en fait c'est le metteur en
scène donc moi je me suis complètement
déchargé de ça et de ton rôle tout ça et
puis je me fie au repère que va me
donner le metteur en scène et en plus il
s'agit d'un film sur effectivement la
guerre de 14 avec tout ce que ça
implique historiquement et tout est
précisions qui ça doit apporter mais en
même temps on est sur une histoire assez
intime en fait où c'est ça qui prime
c'est la la véracité en fait de de et la
crédibilité de ce lien entre le père et
le fils qui prime et le truc de
l'histoire ça reste le décor ça reste
très important mais c'est quand même en
second plan c'est quand même dans le
décor et je trouve que passer par ça il
y a de vrai là ça permet de raconter le
reste donc comme on est passé par cette
voix on était aussi un peu protégé
déchargé par le on va dire le poids
historique c'est pas un documentaire
c'est l'histoire de sperme voilà ce fils
dans un contexte qu'on découvre
exactement de guerre voilà exactement et
justement on disait on est au Montréal
de Verdun aujourd'hui je me suis dit
tant qu'à faire on a l'habitude de finir
ces interviews avec des choses qu'on
apporte dans des cadres différents
Angèle c'était des gaufres ouais c'était
vraiment autre chose je me suis dit
autant en profiter autant essayer de
voir d'observer certains objets qu'il y
a dans ce musée là normalement il y a
Quentin qui doit être pas loin ici qui
est chargé de collection et d'inventaire
dans ce musée qui du coup va nous
apporter certains objets de cette époque
a accomplissent les découvrir super
salut Quentin Salut Bonjour Quentin du
coup qu'est-ce que tu fais tu es au
centre de ce musée pour avoir le
contexte alors moi je suis donc chargé
d'inventaire des collections je m'occupe
de tous les
qui sont arrivés ici ou mémorial fait en
don et je leur donne en fait une une
existence d'autres musées donc du coup
les dons ils viennent d'où généralement
dans un premier temps ça va être surtout
les combattants eux-mêmes qui nous ont
apporté ces objets gracieusement parce
que il voulait garder ce souvenir là
puis ensuite quand c'est descendants ont
commencé à disparaître ça va être leur
famille aujourd'hui encore on a beaucoup
de d'objets qui ne sont importés
gracieusement par par la descendant et
la famille des combattants
même si on met des petits baignoire
comme toi j'en ai pas sous la main je
vais les apporter
avec les yeux
et après cette fameuse base tu la
connais cette vanne c'est vieux quand on
était petit tu touchais avec les yeux on
faisait ça
voilà de l'école primaire que je ressors
aujourd'hui
bon alors les objets qu'on a ici je
pense qu'il y en a qu'on devine il y en
a qu'on devine moins ce que tu as une
idée de ce que c'est celui-là le bout là
je peux le voir de plus près en touchant
avec les yeux évidemment pas de problème
c'est un truc à avoir avec le tabac non
non pas du tout rien avec le tabac non
pas du tout aucune idée c'est un encrier
en fait tout simplement
un encrier qui a probablement été fait
par un soldat français ou autre dans
l'immédiat arrière front c'est ce qu'on
appelle l'artisanat tranché l'encrier
c'est simple c'est servir à la
correspondance sur le côté français on
estime à peu près 2 millions de lettres
envoyées chaque jour chaque jour ouais
entre le front et les positions arrière
donc à toute la guerre pendant toute la
guerre en estimation assez haut ouais
puis rapidement toi qui du musée tu sais
combien de jours déjà pour la bataille
300 jours
j'ai fait d'histoire j'ai pas fait les
maths on va se faire se calcule juste
pour nous
parce qu'il faut faire le nombre de
lettres si tu comptes tous les jours moi
ça me fait vraiment beaucoup et nous
mémorielle de Verdon on en a énormément
et les autres du coup qu'est-ce que
qu'est-ce qu'on a ici
c'est vrai que quand on les voit comme
ça on a pas l'impression parce ça fait
bouquin mais tu sens le briquet quand
même elle a petite subtilité c'est beau
en tout cas c'était quoi la matière
utilisée là c'est de la récupération en
fait quand on dit tranchée c'est pas en
première ligne que ces objets vont être
fabriqués créer par contre c'est ici
qu'on va récupérer la matière première
c'est ça à savoir le laiton l'aluminium
l'acier ou autre matière et toutes ces
matières dans mon métalliques viennent
des munitions c'est ça étui obus étui au
but du début équipement diverses etc etc
et après lorsque le soldat toute sa
matière brute il retourne en position
arrière lors du cantonnement pour se
reposer et c'est à ce moment-là où il va
avoir le temps en fait le temps et les
outils l'espace pour pouvoir créer ces
petites choses qu'on vous présente ici
l'avant dernier ici qu'est-ce que c'est
j'ai pas le nom mais c'est qu'on met
autour des jambes là exactement
dans le film
des bandes c'est pour ça que tu as
oublié
et le dernier du coup un casque casque
qui a vécu qui a pris des chats
très différents de ceux qu'on peut voir
dans le film oui oui alors pourquoi donc
là on est vraiment sur un casque que un
tirailleur sénégalais aurait pu porter
l'insigne de le montre en fait là on a
l'insigne des troupes coloniales hors de
métropole donc tout ce qui est Afrique
de l'Ouest notamment et les tirailleurs
sénégalais faisait partie de ces trous
là et la couleur kaki où on est moutarde
essentiellement là-bas en fait
donc les troupes colonial et l'armée
d'Afrique porter cette couleur là afin
de se différencier plus ou moins de
l'armée de métropole qui était elle en
Blue Horizon oui il y avait pas encore
la notion de camouflage à cette époque
là c'est à ce moment-là que le
camouflage et militarisé
des artistes se réunissent pour dire là
comment on fait pour commencer
la couleur un peu désert pour le désert
et tout vraiment pour se différencier de
la troupes de métropoles
je sens de des tournages je sens que tu
aies des éléments qui sur terre
Quentin pour la présentation
ils sont exposés ou pas du tout cela
déjà le casque et les bandes motières
oui sont exposés juste derrière moi
d'accord et le reste sont dans les
réserves en attente soit d'être exposé
un jour ou utiliser pour des
valorisation etc alors les Asos ça veut
dire vous les vendez non on fait des
postes sur les réseaux sociaux on fait
des présentations à des publics etc
juste pour vous montrer un peu comme ça
voilà un peu comme exemple
tu t'entraînes en fait sur notre tête
merci beaucoup en tout cas merci pour
cette présentation et c'est une bonne
façon de déterminer les chances on
termine par l'encrier une petite lettre
qu'on vous envoie c'est air du numérique
on est sur Youtube mais on parle de
l’encrier c'est bien le c'est vrai il y
a un lien qui se passe
ton temps c'était un vrai bon moment de
passer avec toi et j'espère que les gens
ils vont voir le film j'ai beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup aimé j'ai eu la chance
de le voir avant sa sortie merci donc
bravo pour pour ça merci à vous et merci
aussi à tous ceux qui ont regardé du
coup cette interview là de regarder
en plus c'est pas bon j'ai pas
totalement prêt à bien cueilli au rôle
en gel mais j'espère qu'elle est cette
recette de la réponse hein
si jamais pourquoi pas ça l'intéresse et
merci à vous d'être chaque jour plus
nombreux à suivre aussi ces interview là
je peux vous les découvrir les autres
interviews c'est directement sur cette
chaîne Youtube pensez du coup à vous
abonner chez mes parents le cas on est
quand même sur Youtube pour ne pas
louper les vidéos suivantes pourtant de
s'abonner prenez soin de vous prenez
soin de nos proches à très vite et
encore merci merci avec plaisir Swan les
Américains dans le fauteuil tu suces
quoi
à très vite salut